we also agreed on to continue to defuse
the tension in the region between the
United States and Iran both our
countries are exerting their concerted
efforts in order to defuse the tension
between Iran and the United States which
also steering the region away from any
devastating war where there is no winner
it will have grave repercussions not
only in the region but on the whole
world
we also reiterated that Iraq should be
set aside from proxy wars and other
regional agendas which will have a
negative impact on the region all these
issues were made clear to the Turkish
Foreign Minister through his meetings we
turkey do not wish to see Iraq turning
into a battlefield for foreign powers
Iraq has its own difficulties and
problems Iraq is combating terrorism and
terrorist organizations like PKK and
ISIL Iraq also is addressing a very
critical task which is is the rebuilding
of the country and Iraq cannot be turned
into a battlefield for full forces and
it cannot be hindered from accomplishing
these tasks we in Turkey are doing all
what we can to steer Iraq away from any
regional conflict just give us a sense
of the main talking points from where
you were what did we hear in that well
depending on the latest tension between
the u.s. and Iran especially after the
killing of general Qasem Soleimani in
Iraq a turkey has stepped up to play
a mediation role between mainly the
United States and Iran this is what they
have set out loudly and the purpose of
this visit by foreign minister Javad
shoulder to Iraq is also again for this
mediation let me first state that turkey
always supports the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of neighboring
countries mainly Iraq Syria and Iran
because also they have some Kurdish
communities and the outlawed Kurdistan
Workers Party are also active in those
countries that's why turkey believes
that the neighbors territorial integrity
and sovereignty is also the same for
itself and Turkey and Iraq has both
economic relations and political
cooperation and from time to time they
come together especially for combating
terrorism issues like fighting against
ISIL and PKK is a very important issue
but this visit was specifically set up
to de-escalate the current tension
between Iran and the United States and
that's why a foreign minister Cho vishal
said that turkey welcomed the relatively
positive statements by both the u.s.
president donald trump last night and
from the Iranian side turkey says it is
committed to it committed to help Iraq
in its reconstruction and it seems
turkey is going to is going to try to
take more steps to be able to mediate
between Iran and to provide to help
actually a contributor on Iraq security
this is what we see a for now that's why
Turkey has been in a diplomatic traffic
from for both international
organizations and neighboring countries
that's almost the same policy that
turkey is trying to conduct with Russia
over Libya as well holla at Muslim
Turkey does seem to be extending itself
quite a bit in terms of dealing with
regional partners stretching itself
somewhat when it comes to international
engagements just reminder specifically
why is it so critical for Turkey to have
a voice in Iraq
well well Heather actually Turkey has
conducted an isolated foreign policy
for decades established especially after
the Turkish Republic was established but
of course the borders are removed
technologies out there and whatever
happens in one side of the world affects
the other
so Turkey has noticed that if there is
an there is an instability or insecurity
especially in a neighboring country it
directly affects its own territory
basically Turkey let's think about Syria
for instance the actually a war in Syria
also has an impact on Turkey because it
also means it also means a immigration
to Turkey turkey is hosting almost 4
million Syrians right now so if there's
this instability and insecurity in Iran
and Iraq it also means immigration it
also means security risks for Turkey
and this goes beyond actually having a
more active a proactive foreign policy
but it is mostly a primarily for turkeys
own security stability and territorial
integrity ok great to get your visa
thank you so much seeing him joining us
there live from Easton